hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt passend zur exotik gerade
anfängt eine erdbeertorte und zwar ist
eine richtig leckere fruchtige torte die
auch in der herstellung nicht so
schwierig ist und im in der torte drin
habe ich einen wiener boden habe eine
stracciatella creme und natürlich auch
er teil mit dabei und ich zeig euch
jetzt wie man diese torte hersteller für
die dort habe ich bereits einen wiener
boden vorgebacken und 2 gibt's das
rezept finden wieder boden bereits auf
einem kanal
und es weiß ist grundrezept das habe ich
jetzt in einer 26 cm form vorgebacken
jetzt folgen noch ein paar zutaten für
die erdbeer creme und zwar brauche ich
dafür 500 gramm erdbeeren 100 gramm
puderzucker 300 g frischkäse in
doppelreihen stufe 250 quark 400
milliliter sahne sonder pass ein
päckchen magazine das entspricht 6
blättern gelatine und 100 gramm schoko
rasten
ich werde zuerst mal die erdbeeren
nehmen und einen teil davon püriert und
zwar 300 gramm und 200 gramm lege ich
noch weg
ich werde jetzt hier im egmatinger ganz
fein die erdbeer master will ich jetzt
in einen kleinen topf und da kommt auch
keine puderzucker mit dazu und die ak
tine ich kenne natürlich auch
stadtmagazine gelatine benutzen aber ich
bevorzuge da immer die pflanzliche
variante jetzt ruhig es einmal gut durch
und lass es dann aufkochen und zwei
minuten lang spur dient kochen und in
der zeit kann ich dann schon mal die
erdbeeren die restlichen erdmann einfach
ein bisschen klein schneiden
die erdbeer masse für dich jetzt um
damit sie schneller abkühlt und zwar
stelle ich immer ganz gerne unter das
gefäß und acrobat aus dem kühlfach dann
geht es nämlich schneider das sollte
jetzt nämlich so etwa lauwarm abkühlen
aber muss es immer beobachten dass es
eben nicht zu schnell fest wird deswegen
stelle ich jetzt hier auf die seite und
kontrolliert und immer ab und zu und
rühren immer mal wieder durch in der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
die sahne steif schlagen mit vier
teelöffel seiner partei
bleiben
jetzt kann ich den frischkäse und den
quark verrühren
das mache ich jetzt hier kurz in der
küchenmaschine aber mit dem
handrührgerät geht es natürlich auch
und auch da kommen jetzt fünf teelöffel
seiner partner treiben
die masse muss nur ganz kurz verrührt
werden und jetzt warte ich einfach noch
ganz schnell
bis die app der masse etwa lauwarm
abgekühlt ist
jetzt ist die masse laura abgekühlt und
ich kann jetzt eins bis zwei esslöffel
quarkmasse direkt zu den erdbeeren geben
und verrühren
das macht mir auch so wenn man zum
beispiel mit gelatine arbeitet so
verliert nämlich die masse nicht wenn
ich sie direkt rein gebe
jetzt kann ich das gemisch wieder
zurückführen zu quark und wie ich es
jetzt vor nicht erfüllt hätte dann hätte
das ganze ein bisschen verliert und man
hätte ebenso chilli blockieren mit der
creme und das schmeckt man eben nicht so
ganz lecker jetzt ganz ganz am weitere
jetzt kann ich noch die sahne unterheben
und dann ist die füllung auch schon
fertig
ich will jetzt ein drittel der creme
direkt auf den tortenboden und zwar habe
ich da einen tollen rahmen drumherum
gesetzt dann wird es verstrichen
darüber verteidigt eine schicht
erdbeeren
die schokoraspeln röhrig ist unter die
restliche cremen geht man natürlich auch
direkt einbringen können
ich habe leider vergessen aber dann
haben wir eben eine zweischichtige krieg
und einen tollen effekt mit drin
die hälfte davon kommt jetzt noch auf
die erdbeeren
dann kommt der teig deckel drauf
und darauf verteidigt noch die restliche
creme
die torte decke gibt's ab und stellen
sie für mindestens drei stunden in den
kühlschrank und danach wird sie dann
noch dekoriert
die torte sitzt gefühlt und jetzt löst
sich einmal den torten rahmen
das geht auch hier am besten mit einem
fahrtenmesser
den rand werde ich jetzt mit einer
palette
jetzt streichen bisschen von der
überschüssigen creme noch an den rand
jetzt habe ich hier bereits wasser
auftreten wird darin etwas kuvertüre
schmelzen und zwar bis 400 gramm tabak
ouvertüre und davon gebe ich jetzt zwei
drittel ins wasserbad und ein drittel
behalte ich zurück das heißt sich
temporäre die kubatur und in der
zwischenzeit während das hier vor sich
hin schmilzt kann ich schon mal den rand
der torte mit den restlichen
schokostreuseln bestreuen
die tochter habe ich jetzt kurz kühl
gestellt die kuvertüre ist mittlerweile
auch geschmolzen jetzt nehme ich sie vom
wasserbad hervor und kann da das
restliche drittel kuvertüre mit rein
geben
und sobald dieses geschmolzen ist hat
die kuvertüre die perfekte temperatur
das sind dann nämlich so etwa 29 30 grad
und inzwischen kann ich schon mal die
erdbahn für die dekoration nehmen und
halbiert
und jetzt kommt die kuvertüre über die
erdbeeren einfach direkt mit dem löffel
in streifen
ich werde die torte noch einteilen und
zwar mit diesem roten einteiler den lege
jetzt direkt auf die torte mit ich
drücke ein bisschen ein ganz genau die
stückchen und da kommen noch die erdbahn
mit drauf
jetzt kann der moratti torte direkt vor
wären ja ich habe den humor des todes
ich will jetzt auch ich will alles essen
sogar dieses papier alles alles okay
sowieso schon nicht mehr in die mitte
gemacht ist doch cool aus ja ich finde
es immer ganz cool aus aber ich finds
zum anschneiden immer ziemlich blöd und
deswegen habe ich jetzt mal hier
außendekor damit man eben gut
durchschneiden private kurze fragen geht
nur zu essen
so finde sich aber jetzt eine ganz
einfache torte also eine die sehr gut
schmeckt und von der deko richtig
einfach mal bitte deinen teller rüber
guck mal hier unten diesen schönen
wiener boden dann die erdbeer creme mit
den erdbeer stückchen drin darüber noch
eine creme mit des stracciatella stücken
gehört und ich gibt es jetzt einmal um
ist eine gabel kennt ihr das mini hunger
dann könnt ihr mich alles essen schmeckt
also ich bin mir sicher dass er schon
schmeckt aber jetzt durch den hammer
kommen dagegen ja sie kuchen seien es
überhaupt geht ich habe hier auf dem
backpapier übrigens voll die stempel
technik gemacht ich finde erdmann eignet
sich zuvor zum stempeln coach voll die
kunst manchmal schmeckt nach yogurette
ja irgendwie schon aber eines sollte es
nicht meine yogurette torte werden als
ich meine yogurette torte aber dass
jetzt eine strapazierte schmeckt gut
also mit dem ja der boden ist richtig
richtig luft ich ja das ist ja auch der
wiener boden
also ich hab das frieder zusammengehauen
richtig lustig diese stücke drehen
dieser mine boden richtig luft die also
echt klasse finde ich auch und vor allem
jetzt zur erdbeersaison richtig genial
den mann hatte er dann immer ganz viele
erdbeeren da weiß wahrscheinlich gar
nicht was man damit alles machen kann
aber ich habe mir dieses jahr richtig
tolle etwas einfallen lassen der rat
wird die hälfte ist alles im grünen
genießen
man muss den kuchen genießen ich habe
ganz vergessen
naja weil sie dieses rezept auch nach
machen wollt dann geht auf meinem blog
self - blog.de doch stets noch mal ganz
genau
und ja also ich für die torte auch
richtig gut vor allem sehr erfrischend
und brauchte
hier müsste um euch die lecker aus oder
die drei hier werde ich auch gleich noch
von abschnitten
deswegen fällt ihr noch kuvertüre übrig
habt könnt ihr gerne noch mehrere so
ehrt beim kassieren und das schmeckt
wirklich sehr moni ganz genial oder
ausgedruckt gehen freut mich also viel
spaß zum nachbacken und bis zum nächsten
mal
jetzt kommt ein stück jahres möglich ich
kann das besondere ich ehrlich sein es
schmeckt nicht unehrlich
nein aber ich bin noch ein foto machen
nur hockey mum fotos macht
da reingesteckt das war ich